aquí queremos calcular cuánto estrés por
0.25 o 3 por 25 centésimos así que los
animo que pausa en el vídeo y que traten
de resolverlo muy bien vamos a trabajar
juntos en este vídeo vamos a explorar
varias estrategias y en el futuro les
voy a mostrar lo que llamamos la
estrategia estándar que van a usar mucho
pero las estrategias que veremos en este
vídeo van a ser muy útiles para entender
lo que significa multiplicar decimales
cómo se relaciona con la multiplicación
de fracciones y cómo la gente que sabe
muchas matemáticas realizan la
multiplicación de decimales entonces
para calcular 3 por 25 centésimos hay un
par de maneras de pensar en esto una es
decir que esto es lo mismo que 3 por y
lo voy a escribir de una manera
diferente 25 centésimos
así que si tengo 3 por 25 de algo cuál
es el resultado cuánto estrés por 25
vamos a ver todos por 25 es igual a 53
por 25 es igual a 75 entonces el
resultado es 75 y no estoy multiplicando
simplemente 3 por 25 sino que estoy
multiplicando 3 por 25 centésimos así
que el resultado va a ser 75 centésimos
escrito con palabras esto es 75
centésimos como lo escribo como un
decimal bueno eso es lo mismo que 0.75
setenta y cinco centésimos otra manera
de conceptualizar lo es pensar en
escribir tres por y voy a escribir esto
como una fracción esta es otra forma de
escribir 25 centésimos
todo esto es equivalente cuánto estrés
por 25 sobre 100 bueno es la misma idea
podríamos decir que esto es igual a 25
centésimos + 25 centésimos + 25
centésimos
va a ser setenta y cinco centésimos que
una vez más es igual a 0.75 si quieren
ver esta multiplicación de fracciones de
manera más formal la pueden ver como 3
sobre 1 por 25 sobre 100 y si
multiplican los numeradores obtienen 75
y multiplican los denominadores y
obtienen 100 de cualquier manera y en
todas estas situaciones vamos a obtener
setenta y cinco centésimos otra manera
de pensar en esto es decir mira esto que
tenemos aquí que es 25 centésimos es lo
mismo que un cuarto así que podríamos
ver esto como 3 por un cuarto de hecho
este es un decimal que es bueno que
reconozcan que es lo mismo que un cuarto
así que lo podemos ver como tres por un
cuarto que es igual a tres cuartos tres
sobre cuatro todo esto es equivalente si
alguien lo quiere escribir como un
decimal deberían saber que tres cuartos
puede expresarse como setenta y cinco
centésimos en general es bueno saber
esto
vamos a hacer unos ejemplos un poco más
complicados digamos que queremos
calcular cuánto es 0.4 x 0.3 pausa en el
vídeo y traten de resolverlo y les daré
una pista traten de expresar esto como
fracciones muy bien lo que tenemos aquí
en blanco lo podemos leer como cuatro
décimos y lo podemos escribir como
fracción como 4 sobre 10 y vamos a
multiplicarlo por lo que tenemos aquí
esto es 3 decimos que podemos escribir
como una fracción iii sería 3 sobre 10 y
podríamos ver esto como cuatro décimos
de tres décimos o tres décimos de cuatro
décimos pero estamos multiplicando estas
fracciones como hemos visto en vídeos
anteriores así que qué está pasando aquí
bueno si multiplicamos los numeradores
obtenemos 12 y si multiplicamos los
denominadores obtenemos 100 así que
obtenemos 12 centésimas y si lo queremos
escribir como un decimal sería 0.1
260 hicimos tal vez no tenga algo
interesante aquí y verán esto más y más
mientras aprenden el método estándar 4
por 3 es igual a 12 pero ahora tengo dos
dígitos después del punto y note en esto
tengo un dígito después del punto aquí y
un dígito después del punto aquí para un
total de dos dígitos después del punto
les estoy dando una pista sobre lo que
vamos a hacer más adelante pero lo
importante en este vídeo es que
reconozcan que pueden expresar estos
números como fracciones y luego
multiplicar las fracciones para obtener
algo expresado en términos de centésimos
y entonces podemos expresar lo
nuevamente como un número decimal